What's up man?
I'm with MTV news,
I was wondering if you had
any MP3s on your computer?
Yeah.
So how many MP3s you
have on your computer?
About 600.
Six or 7,000.
Come again?
Find like 300.
For real?
Where'd you get them from?
Truthfully most of them from Napster.
The first time I heard about digital music
was through Napster.
And I didn't really understand what it was
but I knew I can get any song I wanted.
How many of you download
music from the internet?
Okay.
When I feel like there is an opportunity
to just download everything we want
and not really pay for
it, I started to use it.
19 year old Shawn Fanning
developed the Napster computer program.
Today at BYU he was
treated like a rock star.
It's strange, it's awkward.
I'm not used to this.
He's an awesome guy.
And he's so young too.
So you don't think this is stealing?
Not at all, cause you're
just getting a few songs
that you find interesting.
And seeing what's up.
There was this era of discovery
that felt like the virtual
version of a record store.
I remember you were saying to myself
shortly after downloading my first MP3,
I'm never going to buy music again.
No stealing music!
If people leap drop the system for free,
the creators of copyright
will not get compensated
and the movies and
music will not get made,
it's as simple as that.
When it became possible for
people to get music for free,
there was a lot of outcry
and a lot of concern about,
why do people think it's free?
Why is that right?
If you make something
and somebody takes it
without compensating you,
you're hurt by that.
Everyone would like to
have everything for free.
That's not how we work
and it's not fair, it's not right.
When you got a technology
that gives away what you do free,
how do you compete with free?
I mean...
When Napster hit,
it wasn't just any issue
for the music industry.
Young teenagers, teenagers, mind you,
are coming up with ways
we can get DVD movies
on our computers for free.
Anything that was reducible
to a one or a zero
was potentially available
freely to consumers.
All of this was, from a
music industry executive,
perspective terrifying.
On the flip side,
for the independent artists
Napster was probably a good thing.
It made it so much easier to get exposure.
Probably 96, 97.
I started making my first
songs on the computer
and putting them on the internet.
Then the Napster came out.
Yeah it was pretty,
it was massive, you know.
I'll look on my songs on Napster
and like see, see on it
like a lot, you know.
if a lot of search results came up,
it was like a lot of people had it.
So you could kind of tell
like that, like, wow.
So this stuff's really
spreading, you know.
♪ Making them seize freeze ♪
♪ Interrupted and ease
like it ain't cross ♪
♪ Smoking the kids to
cook heavy and seize ♪
♪ At ease ♪
I think Napster did a lot
for independent artists
at that time.
It was the beginning
of an independent path
to find your following, such
that you can sustain yourself,
have a career without having
a major label or contract.
Benefit was
and is an awesome MC.
But way ahead of his time.
The major labels weren't paying attention
to what was happening in the MP3 world
to their laws,
because the MP3 world
was like a minor leagues.
And if somebody floats
to arise to the top,
then they could, you know,
swim off to that other level.
The old paradigm from the last century,
all he was good for that last century.
The new century,
I look at Napster as being new radio
and people are finding ways
that now you're going to
have a million artists,
in a million labels, now
all in the record game.
♪ I got the destiny for hearing this ♪
♪ Flying people seeing this ♪
♪ Fellow lies from the neck ♪
♪ Down still feeling this ♪
But then the flip side,
to making a living off
of music as a musician
and suddenly your revenue streams,
like cut off from under you, like, yeah,
I totally understand.
♪ Spell lies from the neck ♪
♪ Down neck ♪
♪ Down ♪
I remember Lars from
Metallica was like, you know,
he was really mad about it.
Napster hijacked our music without asking.
They never sought our permission.
Our catalog of music simply
became available for free
downloads on the Napster system.
The argument I hear a lot
that music should be free,
must then mean the musicians
should work for free.
Nobody else works for
free, Why should musicians?
Drummer Lars Ulrich and
his band mates saying,
Napster is illegal
and filed suit against its creator
for copyright infringement.
Most artists weren't really too thrilled
with being on the other side
of the kind of the hip
hot new young thing.
But Lars was frankly unafraid
to get out there.
If they want to steal Metallica's music
instead of hiding behind their computers
in their bedrooms and dorm rooms
and just go down to Tower records
and grabbed them off the shelves instead.
When I saw Lars Ulrich
going on that campaign,
I just remember thinking
that was the lamest thing
I'd ever seen.
Like Metallica, you're all millionaires.
So, what are you complaining about?
What's your beef with Metallica then?
Why not let the people listen to music?
As far as I'm concerned, Metallica
is off
my best album.
There was definitely a lot of
hate and a lot of backlash.
My friend definitely said,
yeah, F Metallica, I'm done.
I'm only listening to Nirvana now.
I've removed all the
Metallica files from my,
from my hard drive,
I don't want anything to
do with Metallica anymore.
This mattered to a lot of people.
Napster was like this symbol of freedom.
And so when you have
guys like Lars Ulrich,
trying to shut Napster down,
you're going to have a hell of a backlash.
The largest argument was
the one that I supported
and others in the industry did as well.
But this was an incredibly
disruptive force
in the music industries.
No matter what side of the
argument you came down on.
And the industry had to
shut all of this down.
Using a PC to download music
is one of the hottest of
today's computer trends.
And that has the recording
companies up in arms
and heading to court.
At the center of their dispute,
a music sharing internet
service known as Napster.
The litigation against
Napster was fairly monumental.
They were fighting us
in court, aggressively.
Napster's point of view is like,
we don't personally share any files, Okay?
We just facilitate
connections between users
and we're not responsible for policing
the contents of our network.
Pure and simple.
It was theft of intellectual property.
And I just can't get past
that, that fundamental reality.
I still get agitated
even at this point years later.
Gentlemen, gentlemen.
CNN covered the court decision live.
So there was a lot of pressure.
You know, 25 million
people were using Napster
every single day and really
invested in the outcome.
In the end, the judge ruled that,
it was obvious to everyone at Napster
that they knew what was going on.
Napster appealed that and lost again.
In a 68 page opinion,
the appeals court said,
Napster knew its users were violating
copyright infringement laws.
To song swapping service this weekend
will begin blocking access
to millions of musical files on Napster.
We stopped the sharing.
We basically took the servers offline.
Over a period of time the obligations
to the creditors just
overwhelmed the company
and there didn't seem to be
any way to get revenue in
and so the board determined at that point,
the best thing to do would
be to go into bankruptcy.
The days of free music with
Napster folks are over.
It felt like it was
really dark horrible day
in San Francisco.
I was depressed, lots of
people were depressed.
Technology had lost.
But then of course,
the mole started popping
all over the place.
There are already dozens of alternatives
to Napster,
with names such as My Napster,
Napigator,
and Cute MX.
We had other file sharing services crop up
that were in many ways more insidious.
There was no centralized server
that the files passed through.
And that was much more
difficult to address.
Even if they cracked down
on one program like Kazaa
or something,
I think there's going
to be another program
coming out in the next week or two,
that's going to be doing the same thing.
The huge, huge problem
at the time is that,
it was very hard to tell people not to use
peer-to-peer methods and they'll say,
well, what should we use?
And the answer was, go to a
record store and buy a CD.
That's not what they wanted to hear.
The record companies have to wake up
and I think they will,
to the fact that they're
no longer in the business
of hiring trucks and having big warehouses
and shipping CDs around.
People want their music via the internet.
The answer to the piracy
was to give people
what they otherwise wanted,
in a legitimate way,
at a fair and reasonable price.
We needed to have a
legitimate online music store.
The labels tried in their own lame ways
to debut digital music
stores of their own,
which were total failures.
I remember trying to use these things
and on these special players
and it was just,
it was really pretty antediluvian
and nobody really signed
up for these things.
For the longest time,
there is such a divide
between Silicon Valley
and the music industry.
You know, it was just a big war.
It was not in the software
industry's interest
to help the music industry.
They sold a lot of computers
because people wanted to get their music
and other content for free.
The music companies, they said, you know,
you guys are all promoting piracy
and the tech guys are like, Oh,
you guys are a bunch of Luddites,
you don't understand you have
to change your business model.
And the one guy who was
able to bridge that divide,
was Steve Jobs.
I've been back about,
eight to 10 weeks
and we've been working really hard.
And what we're trying to do,
is not something really highfalutin.
We're trying to get back to the basics.
Steve Jobs had been fired at Apple
and then been brought back.
And at the time, he,
Apple was in some ways,
a bit player in the computer space.
The Mac products,
represented about 3% market share.
This company is absolutely
going to turn around.
As a matter of fact,
I think the question now
is not, can we turn around Apple?
I think that's the booby prize.
I think it's,
can we make Apple really great again?
In 2001,
he introduced the iPod.
There it is, right there.
So, Steve saw a great opportunity
in the music space for Apple.
Music has been around for a long time.
You know, it's a real tangible market.
And, I think if we can bring
some value to that market,
then we'll succeed.
In late 2002,
Steve Jobs called and said
that he was going to create
an online music store.
And I saw that as the perfect
opportunity to at least say,
all right, we've got something out there.
We came up to Cupertino
and went into a conference room
and Steve walks in.
I don't think we even knew
that that was going to happen.
But he walks in and says,
I want to show you the iTunes store.
And then he sits there for two,
himself with the mouse,
showing how the store would work.
He was like a little kid in a candy store.
Absolutely, you know,
fascinated with this thing
that I remember thinking,
it's so simple.
And in fact it was, but
that's what made it brilliant.
It worked better than anything
we'd ever seen before.
And it became obvious this,
this was a good thing to go with.
The one thing of course
about the iTunes music store,
he wanted every song to be a buck.
Steve Jobs wanted to sell singles,
off of every album that was on iTunes.
He did not want a single
album on the store
that you could not breakdown in singles.
That had, you know, really
serious ramifications.
You know, for the music industry,
there would be unbundling the album.
A CD is a bundle.
It's a bundle of songs,
if you want one song,
you the entire package.
Bundles inflate the total revenue
because people are kind
of forced to pay up a bit.
So let's take a canonical example,
which would be Vanilla Ice.
I would be surprised if most people
can't name more than one Vanilla Ice song.
But Vanilla Ice sold something
like 10 million albums
on the basis of just one hit song.
So 150, $160 million in revenue.
Once you liberated that
single from the album,
now excess income from the compact disc
would go away forever.
You would only earn a small fraction of
what you previously earned.
They knew this was going to hurt them.
It's , say it as a music fan,
but it seems like music
is almost disposable now.
You would put out an album,
what, every six years,
tour for those six years,
off of that one album,
but now having to put out a
single and then three singles
and then all of a sudden,
it's just a string of singles
with no cohesion like an album.
And, really the songs
don't have as much meaning
to you as they did back then.
The pitch that Jobs
made to the majors was,
we will save you.
It was like a siren song.
There was no choice.
Really, about anyone
who's thought about it,
there was no choice.
Today, we've got 200,000 tracks
and all of this music
with all of these rights,
you can buy,
for 99 cents per song.
It's called, iTunes.
iTunes online music store.
The iTunes music store.
They've really just created, you know,
what we've all been waiting for,
which is a purely digital
music marketplace.
iTunes did spectacularly well.
You had that great growth of downloads.
iTunes, recently sold
its 50 millionth song.
But the deal the industry made with Apple
to me was a huge mistake.
The unbundling of albums meant,
that the revenue that came in
was significantly diminished.
We were hopeful that the physical product
was hold on longer than that.
As it turned out, it didn't.
CD sales, have dropped almost one quarter
in just three years.
That's an awful lot of lost business.
Buyers got very fed up with spending $18
when there's only one
or two songs they like.
This change with iTunes
made people so upset
that people actually start taking
the products off the platform.
Estelle had an album that had come out
and the label found out that
about 90% of the purchases
were just a one song, American boy.
They pulled the entire album
off of platform for three weeks
before caving in and putting it back on.
Really, they were desperate.
And they decided what they would do,
was go after the end users
of the peer-to-peer sites.
The average file sharer,
John and Jane download.
This was extremely controversial
within the record industry.
Hilary Rosen, the head of the RIAA,
actually resigned in protest.
I didn't want us to go
against individuals,
even though they were the source of
a huge amount of illegal activity,
I felt like ultimately
they were still music fans.
But essentially I was kind of overruled.
My last day at the RIAA was the day before
the litigation against
individuals started.
Yesterday, the music
industry took another step
for the first time,
going after people downloading
and swapping music online.
We want people to stop
engaging in the theft of music.
So that people can go on making it.
I don't remember if I got
it, via letter or email.
But I basically got
what looked like a scam
from the RIAA saying,
you owe us for having downloaded music.
I honestly ignored it, cause
I didn't care and I got,
they sent another letter saying,
I could be sued for up
to $30,000 per song,
of which there were thousands.
I didn't have that much money.
I don't think anyone did.
I wasn't ever really
worried about getting fined
for downloading MP3s mainly because
I was using my mom's computer
and I was kind of an ,
so I was like, Oh my mom's
going to get fined, not me.
Like, you can't take a
13 year old's income,
when he doesn't have any income.
They filed something like 17,000 lawsuits.
Rather than going after the big infringer,
they ended up suing
children and grandmothers
and people who were dead
and you know, moms.
Bonnie Bassett was shocked
to be slapped with a lawsuit
for the hundreds of songs,
her teens downloaded off
the internet for free.
My kids go to Catholic school, we pray,
we brought them up right,
no one in our family has
been arrested, I mean,
we don't steal, We don't steal.
It's just rid...,
It was absurd. It was absurd.
I'm not downloading anything ever again.
I mean, not even screensavers.
Almost everybody was forced to settle,
often for a relatively
small amount of money,
like three or $4,000.
But in the end, this just
made people hate them.
They don't create a deterrent effect,
it just made them loathed.
You know, I've been an
avid record collector
for over 40 years.
Right.
I've got nearly 10,000 records.
And you turned a music fan
into an enemy.
In fact, more people
probably went to piracy
as a result of this than anything else.
I ended up having to pay like,
I think close to a thousand
dollars to the RIAA.
But in the end I ended
up recouping my losses
by downloading overtime and doubling down.
Between the piracy and the unbundling,
the industry recognized
that it was on a decline.
And over the course of, you know,
15 years,
shrank significantly.
Industry revenue,
I think in 99 was worldwide 34 billion
and it fell to something like 16 billion.
The industry was just
destroyed, annihilated.
A simple dynamic in business,
when an industry is under threat,
you consolidate.
which is a
fancier word for cutting costs.
You put two big music
enterprises together,
you can eliminate a whole bunch of Jobs.
I'm currently standing in
front of what used to be the
Virgin Mega store union square,
closed in June of 2009.
And is now Duane Reade and a Citibank.
This building formerly
used to be tower records.
It was the first tower
records in New York.
That window right there
where the light is,
that floor I worked on,
was the,
oldie section.
CD sales were dipping
since I think like 2000, 2001.
That's where the decline really kicked in.
I can't even remember the
last time I physically went
and bought a CD.
What 2006 happened,
was all over for me.
That was the end of it.
It was much I could do.
Tower records may be toppling,
the music chain is preparing
to file for bankruptcy next week.
When tower was bought out,
a lot of us,
the employee that worked there,
we fell into like a depression.
We were like, wow, this, this is it.
Tower is going to be gone for good.
How do I feel about it?
Crappy.